The Joe Rogan Experience the other thing
they did the only thing that I saw in
Pharma
personally that was shady is they would
they would do these courses on never off
label promote don't talk about this
don't talk about that and you would sign
all these documents saying I'm not going
to talk about this yeah definitely and
then a week later have us come listen to
a thought leader in the field off label
promoting all the [ __ ] they told us not
to talk about explain off-label
promotions so uh let me think of an
example uh an example would be Zyprexa
and they got exposed for this on Zyprexa
Zyprexa was indicated essentially for
let me I'll do it a better one if you
look at Oxycontin how did Oxycontin take
over the marketplace it's because what
they did is they got the Reps to go out
and begin to recommend oxy so originally
oxy was meant for people who were like
terminally ill with cancer and were in
severe pain or somebody who's on the
upper echelon of the pain threshold and
the goal of a company and a rep is to
grow the market and to hit the number
and so when you go go out it's like how
do you grow the market well we're going
to grow the patient demographic we're
going to have to grow we're getting we
need the doctors to write more of this
so what they did with Oxycontin was they
went out and started it got to a point
where they were literally promoting it
for people with migraines uh and they
were put pumping these pain pills into
all these practices was this before or
after it had been proven that it was
highly addictive
um they knew it was highly addictive
based off the study so I know you and I
have talked about toxic but let me all
the story on this family is
absolutely insane so the family that
owned uh Oxycontin is one of the richest
families in the country they're up there
with the Rockefellers and the
Vanderbilts they made all of their
wealth in the 1960s by creating
the volume pandemic they launched Valium
into the marketplace told people that it
was non-addictive non-abusive grew the
market they were writing Valiums for
headaches Valiums for knees shoulder
elbow pain and it created they they went
under governmental investigation the
government ended up investigating the
family in the 60s and then jump forward
they they get off they buy their way out
of that jump forward
and this is another thing we'll talk
there's so many data points uh
their patent on hydrocodone was expiring
so big Pharma does this a lot and I'll
get into this like they they say we
innovate but it costs 10 times we make
tenfold on one drug because we innovate
and so many go by the wayside they don't
innovate they re-engineer and reapply
and like Zyprexa uh got combined with
symbiaks to EXT Two drugs that were
already on the market to extend the
patent right so the goal is to play this
shell game where you when your patent's
close to expiring you have to reapply
and extend the patent via a new
indication or some sort of new
combination of a couple of different
products and so hydrocodone was expiring
the hydrocodone oxy like long delivery
system was it or uh the cotton system
was expiring so what they did is they
looked at their revenues and they're
like we're [ __ ] like we we can't we
won't hit our numbers we can't continue
these growth trajectories unless we get
a new patent on a new pain med so they
went out and they said what else is out
there that we could put into our
patented delivery system and the answer
was oxy and the problem with that is
it's 10 times more addictive than
Hydrocodone
so then you go okay well they're going
to have to do safety studies and prove
it in humans and show that it's not
addictive not abusive nope human study
never happened they were able to
piggyback on their hydrocodone cotton
delivery system take the delivery
mechanism and all it is is basically the
ground up the powder and they create
layers So in theory if you take the pill
you won't get 100 milligrams of oxy at
once it'll over eight hours dissolve
into your body and you'll get that
absorption that was the premise and so
they said because of our patented
delivery system this drug is non-abusive
non-addictive we have a great safety
profile uh the other thing that happened
is they went to the FDA and this is
where there's a lot of [ __ ] they they
literally met with the head of the FDA
at the time after hours at a hotel this
is all documented now and he helped them
draft their application then rubber
stamped it and pushed it through and
gave Oxycontin the golden [ __ ] ticket
he put in the label that Oxycontin is
less likely to be addictive or abusive
compared to other opioids in the market
and then you give a rep that and you set
them out in a Marketplace and you give
them a twenty thousand dollar a month
expense account and you have them taken
guys to dinner drinking wine and eating
steaks and they show in the label hey
we're less addictive this is a safe drug
we've got to stop pain you know let's
let's really this isn't just any more
for the cancer patient this is anybody
in your practice who has pain we're on a
mission to stop pain and all of them
started getting addicted I mean it was
rampant and the the system was trash
because once you grind up the pill
you've just circumvented the delivery
mechanism and now it's super addictive
because they're going to get high doses
of an opioid
and that's what a lot of people were
doing that were abusing him right they
were grinding it up and snorting it out
and then they it reminded me a lot with
covid because what happened is patients
were doctors were blowing the company up
Purdue Pharma as the name of the company
and the families the sacklers so the
Sackler family this is all documented
now and also Jamie anything I bring up
I've put on the ways to well website
slash JRE uh because we're gonna go over
a lot of stuff so any data point or
study or any of that I bring up is
available on the website
um
what they did was uh the Sackler family
ended up taking a agreement with the U.S
government and
part of that deal was they would pay I
think three billion dollars and then
there was no uh
they could not prosecute them or come
after them criminally and it was done so
they was just set a three billion
dollars go well they made I think nine
or 12 billion nine to two billion I
can't remember the number but the three
that I don't know if it goes to the
family or the government I don't know
I'm not sure where at all if it went to
the families of people and this hits
close to home for me because my brother
died of opioids my brother died at 27.
man and it's I watched that documentary
and it makes me want to [ __ ] vomit
I'm just like and it and it's not just
the sacklers it's you know Johnson and
Johnson they're known for their diapers
and their uh no teary eyes baby soap
Johnson and Johnson made more than
anybody during the opioid pandemic they
were literally growing they were doing
what people doing the marijuana trade
they were turning
basically juicing up and synthetically
altering opioid plants to grow faster
and more potent so they could turn them
over quicker and so they supplied all
the Opium into the United States and
made billions of dollars billions of
dollars and the FDA uh at this point in
time the uh DEA was getting involved
going to the FDA going to all these
governmental bodies and saying look this
shit's getting crazy like this is
getting out of control the addiction
rates are through the roof
what Purdue did at that time was pivot
and go out and educate doctors on
breakthrough pain these patients aren't
addicted they're just still in pain and
the way to fix it is to write a more
opioids so they launched a 200 milligram
pill
and gave people more opioids oh my God
there's a tragic uh
that the one that is dope sick is is
like a docu-series but it's not a
documentary it's like we're a fictional
reality yeah
um there is a documentary documentary
and it's tragic it's this Mormon family
and he talks about this is the level of
bravado that Physicians oftentimes have
his wife they grew up Mormon and they
had been married they had multiple kids
and the story is his wife got in a car
wreck injured her neck and was doing
okay she was seeing a primary care
doctor and a neighbor said you need to
go to the pain clinic and go meet Dr so
and so
long story short he puts her on oxy he
puts her on a bunch of other meds uh she
ends up passing out all over the house
the husband's like taking pictures of
her to document for the doctor and she
ends up in the ER at one point
after she gets out they put her in rehab
they get her clean again and that
Doctor's practice reaches back out and
asks to meet with the family and the
wife this is like a true story in this
docu-series and when when the doctor
meets with them and I've seen stuff like
this happen the doctor said
I and I alone will make the medical
decisions on my patient not you
so
are we on the same page here and this
this guy said I looked him in the eye
and I said yes sir anyways the guy's
wife OD'd and died like literally a
month later and so they're suing the
doctor they're suing his practice so the
doctor got her back on pills doctor got
it back on pills and what was his
justification
what's this is where it gets so tough
because when you're in it like when I
was in it like erectile dysfunction in
in Viagra like I said Cialis that's fun
right but some of the drugs you're you
are really passionate about like and so
I I think he I do believe that
there's good and bad in every person
right and sometimes people's egos get in
the way and he's probably been to course
after course I mean the narrative they
spent in this is he made hundreds of
thousands of dollars in Consulting fees
from Purdue Pharma and was paid as a
consultant and over a time span made I
think like three or four hundred
thousand dollars off Purdue Pharma and
so of course he's gonna push Purdue
pharma's product
um is is the narrative but what I saw a
lot was you begin to drink the Kool-Aid
and bleed the belief if that makes sense
um like this is we're changing the world
we're gonna launch these pain meds in
there because you're being financially
incentivized for it so you have a reason
to think you have a reason to be skewed
and then you're opening the door to let
yourself be educated in a biased manner
does that make sense you're only
listening to half the narrative and
that's a problem uh and a lot of times
Physicians are listening to the big
Pharma company rather than their
patients
God damn
so I mean I experienced that like we had
a drug
um Strattera
um and it it wasn't like a dangerous
drug it was a really safe drug meant to
treat children with ADHD and I was
passionate about it like I believed in
it because I [ __ ] failed kindergarten
I literally went to pre first there were
kids in my class with helmets because I
was ADHD and dyslexic and at the time
the only thing on the market was Ritalin
and they said we want your son on
ritalin or we're recommending that he
goes to like special education basically
uh so I had to go to a brief first and
and then not jump forward I'm 23 and had
graduated college and I'm making great
money and I see this drug that
is non-abusive non-addictive that we
could be using to treat ADHD in kids and
have them not go through all the
headaches that I went through as like an
ADHD kid I was like this is amazing
instead of Adderall and all these stuff
um and so you bleed it like you get
really passionate about it when you buy
in and nothing bad ever happened with
that drug it wasn't as efficacious as
the company presented it to be it didn't
seem to work as effectively
um it's not always the case though I
mean is there a lot of times a drug
other than Cialis yeah which really does
what it advertises yeah but is there are
there I mean that's kind of always the
case that they exaggerate the benefits
well the biggest challenge is not only
the exaggeration potentially of the
benefits it's the
if they begin to re-engineer or apply it
to a different disease State
um
I'm trying to think of an example that
would be a good one to give you they can
they can take a drug and the patent's
about to expire all right so let's say
they have a year left on the patent at
that point the company will begin to say
how do we extend the patents so we can
continue to get insurance coverage and
get paid and hit our numbers for Wall
Street we've got to get another
indication so when they resubmit for a
new indication based off just efficacy
they do not have to go back and do
safety studies
and so they don't do human trials
and so what they're doing is they're
they're piggybacking but the dosages may
change the disease States change the
patient population's changed yeah it may
have been safe you know as uh
osteoporosis drug and 60 year old women
but is it safe now that you're using it
in a 20 year old girl you know like
that's the type stuff that happens all
the time
um and the guy who approved Purdue
Pharma this is the craziest part the one
who helped them draft their agreement
and all that guess where he went to work
18 months later
Purdue Pharma
making 300 Grand a year which is always
the case whether it's in the financial
sector or in medical yeah right that's
what they do they always wind up working
for some enormous Corporation after they
set the regulations that would benefit
that Corporation they get a cushion job
yeah I think it was
um 12 out of the last 15 heads of the
FDA have taken jobs with in Private
Industry for a big medical or big Pharma
God
and so I I will say being behind the
scenes
it's the same I've heard you say this
about police officers 90 of people I
think are trying to do good they're good
people but there are outliers in every
capacity of Life period just because
somebody works for the government
doesn't mean they're good and just
because somebody's a doctor doesn't mean
they're good and just because somebody's
a rep doesn't mean they're bad I didn't
see very many bad reps like there
weren't I didn't see unethical when I
say bad I mean like I didn't see a lot
of unethical reps they existed like I'm
not saying they didn't but not
disproportionately any more than I saw
in the rest of society